it's been one year now since
china's hong kong security law was
passed beijing says it will bring
stability to a
city that was home to massive democracy
protests
the law criminalizes acts of subversion
succession
collusion with foreign forces and
terrorism
all can be punished by life in prison
critics say
the legislation gives beijing the power
to silence critics and punish
pro-democracy
activists dw's phoebe kong has
met one of the few young activists in
hong kong still speaking up
writing his politics and his love of
hong kong into his skin
they'll be with wang yat-chin even in
the darkest days
i hope they remind me of the beliefs i
started with even if i'm jailed in the
future
wong started the group student
politicism last may
just after hong kongers heard about the
national security law
at 20 he's one of the oldest in the
group they're as young as 15.
there's some of the few still visible on
the streets many other groups are gone
i decided not to go to college last year
i wanted to dedicate myself to activism
while i was still free
now many political influencers seldom
speak in public
people fear they could be caught under
the national security law
especially with it being so uncertain we
feel like we have to step up
especially when prominent figures are
either in jail
or in exile
wong has been arrested four times in the
last year twice just this month
marches are banned under pandemic rules
he and his group hand out leaflets
instead
but it's enough to get him into trouble
the pressure is intense
he knows national security officers are
watching him
he doesn't go to sleep until 7 a.m so
he's awake at dawn
that's when police arrest people at home
he's part of what beijing says
is an extremely small minority that the
national security law targets to
preserve
stability
one thing i see stability brought by the
national security law is just an
illusion and is built on people's fear
there's no room for further retreat what
if even the terms freedom and democracy
become taboo one day i won't compromise
on my speech
he and his group support those already
in jail they take supplies to protesters
behind bars
hong kong's future is more important
than my own future
when the political prisoners are
released in years or decades to come
i don't want them to return to a worse
hong kong a hong kong
without hong kongers
many say we are the kids chosen by the
times
but i think it's we who have chosen this
era
the symbols on his skin state his
certainty
the tattoos are messages of defiance
to his future self
and our correspondent phoebe kong joins
us now from hong kong
phoebe you have followed developments
there in hong kong for
the past year and long before of course
too
what has changed since beijing's
security law came into effect
well 117 people were arrested uh
over the past year many of them were
opposition politicians activists and
journalists the youngest one was only 15
years old
more than half of them have been
prosecuted so far and since the
implementation of the law protests have
been
almost completely deterred although the
authorities say that
the law only targets and affects an
extremely small minority as mentioned in
the report
but uh like its impact is actually much
far-reaching and reaches into
many aspects of people's everyday lives
say
we have seen a significant retreat of uh
and self-censorship among the media
apple daily was just
a pressure to shut down last week and uh
other than that the government schools
are now
restructuring the curriculums to
implement what beijing defines as
national security education and even
arts and cultural sectors
new rules have been set up to censor
movies and books from public libraries
so the law um has really largely changed
the
atmosphere on the ground that people are
getting more cautious if not fearful
about the expression since then
now amnesty international says that in
one year
the law has put hong kong on quote a
rapid path toward becoming a police
state and creating a human rights
emergency phoebe
what does this mean for rights activists
how are they holding on to any hope in
this situation
well to be honest like we have spoken to
many activists and people involved in
activism they admitted that there is
little room for them to
um like carry on street activism on the
streets and because of the tightening
grip of beijing
and so they have to resort to other ways
maybe not on the streets and other forms
to support the child protesters or
or even just to keep some of the
cultural elements of hong kong hoping
there will be a chance for them to fight
back
phoebe thank you very much that was our
correspondent phoebe kong
in hong kong